- [Instructor] So we have a type of
statistical study described here.
I encourage you to pause
this video, read it,
and see if you can figure out,
is this a sample study, is
it an observational study,
is it an experiment?
And then also think about
what type of conclusions
can you make based on the
information in this study.
Alright, now let's work on this together.
British researchers were
interested in the relationship
between farmers' approach to their cows
and cows' milk yield.
They prepared a survey
questionnaire regarding
the farmers' perception of
the cows' mental capacity,
the treatment they give to the cows,
and the cows' yield.
The survey was filled by all
the farms in Great Britain.
After analyzing their results,
they found that on farms
where cows were called by name, milk yield
was 258 liters higher on average
than on farms where this was not the case.
Alright, so they're making a connection
between two variables.
One was whether cows called by name,
whether,
whether cows named, alright.
Whether
cows
named
and this would be a categorical variable
because for any given farmer
it's gonna be a yes or a
no, that the cows are named,
and so they're trying to form a connection
between whether the cows are named, and,
and milk yield.
And this would be a quantitative variable,
'cause you can, you're measuring it
in terms of number of liters.
Milk, milk, yield.
Whether we are drawing a connection.
And they are able to draw
some form a connection.
They're saying, hey when the
cows were called by name,
milk yield was 258
liters higher on average
than on farms where this was not the case.
So first is the thing of what
type of statistical study
this is, and we could think, okay,
is this a sample study,
is this an observational study,
observational,
or is this an experiment?
Now, a sample study,
experiment,
a sample study, you would
be trying to estimate
a parameter for a broader population.
Here, it's not so much
that they're estimating
the parameter, they're
trying to see the connection
between two variables, and that
brings us to observational study,
'cause that's what an
observational study is all about.
Can we draw a connection, can we draw
a positive or a negative correlation
between variables based on observations?
So we surveyed a population here,
the farmers in Great Britain,
and we are able to draw some type of
connection between these variables.
And so this is clearly an observational,
an observational study.
Now this is not an experiment.
If it was an experiment,
we would take the farmers
and we would randomly assign
them into one or two groups.
And in one group we would
say, don't name, no name,
no naming, and in the
other group we would say,
name your cows.
And then we would wait some period of time
and we would see the
average milk production
going into the experiment
in the no naming group
and the naming group,
and then we would see,
we wait some period of
time, six months, a year,
and then we would see the
average milk production
after either not naming or
naming the cows for six months.
So this is not what occurred here.
Here we just did the survey to everybody
and we just asked them this question,
and we were able to find this,
we were able to find this connection
between whether the cows were named
and the actual milk yield.
So clearly, not an experiment,
this was an observational,
observational study.
Now the next thing is,
what can we conclude here?
We know when, you know, they're telling us
that when the cows were named,
it looks like there was a 258 liter
higher yield on average.
So, the conclusion that
we can strictly make here,
is like, well, for
for farmers in Great Britain
there's a correlation,
a positive correlation
between whether cows are named
and the milk yield.
So that we can say for sure.
So let me write that down.
So for Great Britain,
for, for Great Britain farmers,
Great Britain farmers,
farmers,
we have a positive correlation.
Positive correlation
between naming cows,
between naming
cows
and milk yield.
And milk yield.
That's pretty much what we can say here.
Now, some people might be
tempted to try to draw causality.
We'll see this all the
time where you see these
observational studies,
and people try to hint
that maybe there's a
causal relationship here,
maybe the naming is actually what makes
the milk yield go up.
Or maybe it's the other way,
the cows produce a lot of milk,
the farmers like them more
and they wanna name them,
because it's like hey, that's
my high milk producing cow.
So, there's a lot of,
there's a lot of temptation to say,
you know naming,
that maybe there's a causality
that naming causes more milk,
more milk,
or that maybe more milk causes naming.
You know, the farmers
really like that cow,
so they start naming them,
or whatever, whatever it might be.
But you can't make this
causal relationship
based on this observational study.
You might've been able to do it
with a well constructed experiment,
but not with an observational study.
And that's because there could be some
confounding variable that
is driving both of them.
So, for example, that confounding variable
might just be a nice farmer.
A nice farmer.
And you know we can define
nice in a lot of ways,
they're gentle, they,
and a nice farmer is more likely to name,
and a nice farmer's more likely to get,
gets a higher yield.
And the reason why this
is a confounding variable,
if you were to control for that,
if you just take, well let's
just control for nice farmers
and then see if naming makes a difference.
It might not make a difference.
If the farmer is, you
know, petting the cows
and treating them humanely,
and doing other things,
it might not matter whether the,
whether the farmer names them or not.
Likewise, if you take
some less nice farmers
who, you know, hit their cows, and
and they have really inhumane conditions,
it might not make a difference
whether they name the cows or not.
And so it's very important that you,
from the observational studies, you might,
if they're well constructed,
you might be able to make a,
you might be able to say
there's a correlation,
but, you won't be able to make a,
drive a causal, or make
a causal conclusion.